Is it a bird?
Is it a plane?
Is it superman?
No! It’s a mosquito getting ready to feast
on your delicious blood.
Summer is the time that insects come out to
play.
From the bite-ey, stab-ey mosquitos and wasps,
to the useful bees and ladybugs,
to the downright weird dragonfly.
But why is it that insects seem to like
summer just as much as us?
Insects are poikilotherms.
That means that their internal temperature
can vary hugely depending on
what’s going on outside around them.
In this way they are actually the opposite
to
humans who are homeotherms.
That means we keep our internal
temperatures nearly constant
and aren’t that fussed about
external temperatures.
Biological processes are
temperature dependant,
which means that insects rely heavily
on the environment for both their development
and their behaviour.
With increasing ambient temperature,
insects see an increase in development,
locomotion, population growth and metabolism.
Basically the insects get
fitter and fitter… until they die.
At very high temperatures insects die
because they basically just dry out.
The lipids that retain moisture in insect
bodies start melting at higher temperatures.
This combined with the fact that
water evaporation rates increase
with increasing temperatures as well,
means that there is a point
where insects lose water faster
than they can take it on.
On the flip side of this -
if the temperatures go too low
the biochemical processes in the body
don’t have enough energy to proceed.
So insects either die
or enter a form of hibernation.
So while all insects benefit from
warmer temperatures,
there are some that have a…
peculiar reaction to summer weather.
Butterflies for example can’t even
fly if it’s not hot enough.
They have an optimal flight temperature
of between 35C and 39C at which they can lift off.
If it’s not quite as hot outside they can
wiggle
their bodies to generate the rest of the heat
needed.
This is because flight is a very expensive
form of energy consumption.
It’s a bit like a jet plane.
The wing muscles of the butterfly
need a steady supply of energy.
In that fuel supply system,
if any part isn’t at the right temperature,
then the whole system won’t work.
One of the more unusual direct effects of
temperature on insects can be seen in crickets.
Now, male crickets chirp to attract a mate.
But their chirping is so closely linked to
ambient
temperature that in fact they’ve been called
nature’s thermometers.
The exact chirping rate differs between species
but as a rule of thumb you can roughly calculate
the temperature in Celsius
by counting the number of chirps
in eight seconds and adding five.
Just as the male’s chirping
is affected by temperature,
a female’s preference for chirping
is affected by temperature too.
Basically, the warmer the female cricket gets,
the faster she wants the chirping song to be.
Summer also brings something
that you don’t automatically connect with
insects -
a nice boozy drink in the sun.
Turns out some insects are just as
affected by alcohol as we humans are.
Wasps that feed on fermenting fruit are
known to get drunk and aggressive,
attacking many a garden lover or picnic aficionado.
And drunken honey bees have been
observed spending a really, really long time
grooming themselves.
And loitering.
And even in some cases drunkenly falling over.
There are however other insects that
deliberately get drunk to get rid of parasites.
A study has found that fruitflies infested
with wasps
seek out alcohol containing fruit as a form
of medication.
Essentially they are trying to
outdrink the wasps because of the
different rates at which alcohol becomes toxic
to them.
But what protects flies against wasps
won’t protect you against mosquitoes.
Because one study found that drinking alcohol
actually makes you more attractive
to blood sucking parasites like mosquitoes.
It might just be time to put down that lager
and have a pint of H2O instead.